tonight well my heart's quite troubled
mitch mcconnell where is your backbone
where are your principles moments ago
mitch mcconnell 10 other weak republican
senators they gave their democratic
colleagues a very generous gift one
they've been telling us for two months
they would not give them and that is a
big new extension of the debt ceiling
now everyone in this country is going to
pay the price until yesterday
republicans had been completely united
they weren't going to budge they were
completely ignored and shut out by
democrats on the budget in the whole
process and they promised us you we the
american people that they would not
assist the democrats in raising the debt
ceiling democrats can do it all on their
own democrats were panicking on capitol
hill technically they had enough votes
they they could have raised the debt
ceiling all summer long and rammed it
through their own reconciliation they
did not need the help of mitch mcconnell
and 10 other weak republicans but
they could not get it done why because
the radical socialist democrats and
their slightly less radical socialist
colleagues they couldn't come to terms
at stake trillions and trillions of
dollars in green new deal socialist
spending and massive new tax hikes
record tax tax hikes record spending
record regulation and you know all they
were trying to do now is ram this
through in the middle of the night along
with the debt ceiling because democrats
could not come to terms they were
threatening to blow up the legislative
filibuster that's right we'll go to the
nuclear option instead of forcing the
democrats hand as they said they would
instead of calling their bluff as they
said they would mcconnell completely
caved to their threats and he did it at
the last minute now thanks to him and
other weak republicans in the u.s senate
democrats well they now have months to
work out a solution and get their 3.5
trillion dollar build back better new
green deal socialist spending bill
through congress mitch mcconnell he
played the typical sewer swamp game
of saying one thing doing another making
a promise and breaking it and by the way
democrats they're now mocking him and
taking a huge victory lap
mcconnell cave that was the headline on
drudge and that was the headline of
senator elizabeth warren
senator elizabeth warren
is correct
mitch caved and this brings us to an
important question for mitch mcconnell
why would you the republican leader in
the senate republicans i thought now i'm
a registered conservative because i've
seen too much of this swamp weakness in
my life so i kind of left the republican
party when you're right i'll defend you
and you know
it's not like i have a chance of
supporting democrats because they're
radical socialists you know why would
you support raising the debt ceiling
knowing what the democrats plans are and
that is to spend the 3.5 trillion
dollars on this socialist green new deal
mcconnell's office claiming that he was
looking to avert a default with a
short-term extension at a dollar
with a fixed dollar amount at least they
responded to us what mitch is not saying
is that he and the republican caucus
said they were united and would not do
this they promised not to do this mitch
now gave democrats this precious time
now they can work out their
disagreements on their massive spending
deal and by the way one that will be
raising taxes at a record level spending
money at a record level and that will
cause uh cause inflation to skyrocket
and it will hurt every american family
already
inflation is costing the average
american household
175 dollars more per month do the math
times 12 that's 2100
that's a biden tax now inflation tax on
every single american household he's
only been in office nine months
gas prices are now at a seven year high
food prices are are up through the roof
the price of raw materials are up you
know look look at for example
everything that you buy everything you
pay for it's up everything's up and now
just think what five trillion dollars in
new spending will do everything you buy
will be more expensive your paycheck
will be less valuable and make no
mistake joe biden's build back better
socialist plan is a down payment for the
10 trillion they really want for their
new green deal socialism you know
government paid family leave guaranteed
job guaranteed government pay guaranteed
government paid child care government
paid college uh
tuition
amnesty if you will when you get oh no
you don't have to pay your your loans
back okay i wish i had that when i was
paying my loan back anyway billions for
illegal immigrants massive womb to the
tomb government entitlements for anyone
unwilling to work i wrote in the book
live free or die america and the world
on the brink socialism it's history of
failure whatever name it's given
whatever manifestation it takes on it
gives the greatest promises of security
we will take care of you okay the same
people that say they keep our city safe
and don't they can't maintain law and
order the same people that destroyed our
school system the same people that
bankrupted social security and medicare
they broke open the lock box and they
squandered the money the same people
that promised to keep your doctor plan
and save money
now the united states is the greatest
wealth creation system ever created it
will be completely upended and our great
economic system will end as we know it
that is what is at stake
mitch mcconnell if you're not willing to
fight
for basic small government
simple conservative principles smaller
government less regulation capitalism
free trade fair trade etc if you're not
willing to fight tooth and now and keep
your promises and protect the country
from what we know doesn't work socialism
it always ends in unfulfilled promises
it always ends in more poverty and it
always ends with people giving up
freedom it's just a matter of how much
freedom you give up in the name of false
security but mitch if you're going to
keep breaking your promises then you
need to step aside we need new
leadership because clearly your word is
worthless hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else